uh welcome everyone
uh today's talk efficient generation of
gene edited
mouse models and cell lines using
synthetic single guide rna
um myself my name is gurpreet bowery
head of business
for europe middle east and africa for
the genome engineering and modulation
franchise within merck kgaa darmstadt
germany
my colleague dr peter romanenko the
managing director for the genome editing
shared resource
at the rutgers cancer institute of new
jersey
is going to be joining me he's going to
be doing part of the presentation
before we begin just to let you know the
life science
business of merck kga darmstadt germany
operates
as military sigma in the u.s and canada
um and work
elsewhere just so you are aware because
we are called different things in
different places
in terms of agenda uh i'll cover merck's
background in gene editing and introduce
some basic
crispr concepts followed by an
introduction to our cgrna synthetic
guide system
i'll then hand over to peter for his
section on their experiences of using
our crna synthetic guides in their
animal model creation
peter will then hand back to me and i
will conclude the talk
with some new data we have on
electroporation and micro injection of
rcrna into mouse embryos
and a couple of data points on the use
of our cgrna and salves
assays we'll then have hopefully ample
time for your questions
so in terms of background and
introduction merck has been heavily
invested
in gene editing reagents for almost 15
years now
we began by supplying gene editing
reagents for prokaryotic research back
in 2005 as you can see on the left hand
side
with a system called targetron two years
later the next big development was
supplying zinc finger nucleases commonly
referred to as zfns
where we commercialized products and
services under an exclusive license
as the first targeted gene editing
reagent from romanian use
moving forward to 2012 and beyond we're
now firmly placed in the crispr era and
we continue
our commitment to supplying cutting-edge
gene editing reagents for model systems
of any kind
along the way we've hit many firsts the
first genome editing tool in zinfandel
nucleases as mentioned
the first genome edited rats with zinc
finger nucleases
the first to show utility of
oligonucleotides as
donors for knocking the first to have a
commercial crisper product on the market
in 2013 and the first to have a whole
genome human
and mouse the antiviral raid library on
the pattern front we now have 26 global
foundational crispr related patents
approved
all in all we have a depth of knowledge
expertise
and suite of cutting-edge products that
is unsurpassed
now when we talk about gene editing in
the present case what we're really
referring to is the targeted cutting of
dna
at a specific predetermined site to
increase mutagenesis frequencies at that
particular
gene editing tools whether they be lfns
or crispr are designed
such that based on a target sequence and
nuclease can be brought to that position
and cause a double-stranded break once
this occurs the scientist relies on the
cell's own repair mechanisms to affect
the type of mutation required
a simple demonstration of what happens
is shown in the slide
most of the time and at all phases of
the cell cycle
the cell has non-homologous and joining
available
this means the cell recognizes that a
cut has occurred
and simply joins the two cut ends
together
most of the time this results in
error-free repair and no mutations
in a small number of cases the result is
error-prone repair
leading to insertions or deletions at
the site
which in turn means a heritable
permanent change in the sequence
therefore hopefully a frame shift this
is then a simple knockout
in the s and g2 phases of the cell cycle
however the sister chromatid becomes
available
as a template for repair and the cell
can use homology dependent repair to fix
the cut
if enough of a plasmid or simple
oligonucleotide bearing resemblance to
the sister connected
by the addition of homology arms is
provided
the cell can be made to insert the
sequence of choice into the cut site
this is then a knock-in or gene
insertion
but brakes induce dna repair and
increase mutagenesis frequencies by
over five over a thousand fold
in terms of what is required for genome
editing using crispr
the crispr system consists of two main
parts
the cas9 protein shown here in green
the guide rna which you can see here
in in purple now the ribonuclear protein
which is what the complex of the two
is commonly referred to glides along the
dna looking for a sequence
complementary to the first 20 or so
bases of the guide rna
it stops at every protospace adjacent
motif or pam site
and checks the 20 bases adjacent to it
and when it finds the correct
complementary sequence
the guide rna binds and unwinds the dna
allowing the cas9 protein to cut exactly
three bases in
from the panels as i said earlier we
have a long history in this area
and mass the most comprehensive suite of
crispr products
on the market we have all-in-one
plasmids
separate plasmids for casini guide rnas
antiviral plasmids
you can package yourself or lengthy
particles ready to go
as well as whole genome arrayed in cool
light reason
panels and libraries are available for
knockout inhibition
and activation this is not an exhaustive
list of course
and we have other products and services
that are not included in this slide
but these are the most relevant to
today's topic however
what we will be focusing on today is on
the far right highlighted in purple
which is rnp and more specifically the
synthetically manufactured rna
component of the rnp
when we talk about sig rna what we're
referring to is both
the two-part system which has the two
rnas involved in
crispr base in in crispr editing as two
separate easily orderable products that
they
that then need to be annealed and
complex with the casino protein so
that's the crna
the transactivating segment rna
um and one part
system which is a one part single guide
rna system which has
the two rnas joined together using a
stem loop structure that does not affect
the ability
in fact as you hear the talk you will
find that in many cases the single guide
rna does outperform the two-part system
there is however a place for both
options and will continue to offer both
to our customers
i'll now hand over to peter so he can
talk you through his slides
thank you very much to peter for
collaborating with us on this talk
and of course with the work we've done
in the past
thank you capri hi i'm peter romanenko i
run the genome editing service at
rutgers university
which is a state university in new
jersey with two medical schools a dental
school
a cancer center and an extremely diverse
array
of research areas i'll go through a few
slides that outline our workflow
show some data we have gotten using
synthetic sgrna
in my summary slide i'll touch on a few
areas for which i won't show data but i
will discuss
our general impression on how synthetic
sgrna seems in part to have improved our
results
currently we use christopher cast9 to
make mouse models and we developed a
workflow that involves
testing crispr guide rnas in a mouse
cell line
which in turn advises us on how to
design
the donor oligo or targeting construct
and then finally we micro inject or
electroporate the crispr reagents and
donor template
into zygotes the methods resources and
reagents we use are just how our
approach has evolved over time it
doesn't mean that this is the best way
it works for us and we are open
to improving our workflow so this slide
lists the steps we take
first we design our guide rnas using the
chris board tool
web tool looking for guide rnas with
minimal off target
and reasonably good predicted activity
that would cut in the vicinity of where
we want to modify or knock into
we transfect the sgrna into cas9
expressing nih 3t3 cells
and check activity by t7 assay
this gives us an idea of in vivo
function and lets us know the
synthesized reagent is biologically
active and not degraded
after we receive and resuspend them so
based on the t7 results
or proximity to where the best guide rna
cuts
we design order an oligo or a targeting
plasmid
once these are ready we electroporate if
we use crispr rmps or oligodonors
or micro-inject if we use rmps and
plasmid donors into mouse cycles
once founders are born we genotype them
and when appropriate analyze the alleles
by ngs
to determine how many alleles there are
how mosaic they may be
so this next slide simply shows
the cell-based sgrna validation we do
initially when we use the two-part
crispr rna system we would transfect
non-complex crm tracer rna
mixed in optimum then with lipofectamine
and place them on cells we monitor
transfection
efficiency using either a gfp or an m
cherry messenger rna
so we see we essentially see 100
transfection the next day using a
fluorescent
microscope and then we can harvest the
dna within 24 hours to do the t7 assay
um i haven't tried to harvest earlier
um so this is a figure i had taken from
aging i think everyone's familiar how
t7 assay works i'll just go through it
to cover all the bases
so the red x's represent mutations
not necessarily the same mutations
across the whole population of
transfected cells
some cells may have one allele or both
mutated
or all of them if they're undeployed
some cells
may have just accurately rejoined the
cut ends or may not have been
transfected at all
and therefore there was no cutting the
genomic dna is amplified
from the population and the products are
denatured and rehybridized to purposely
create
heteroduplex dna this allows different
strands to anneal together where
different mutations are now across from
each other
and then create and they create targets
for t7 and the nucleus one digestion
if two wild type strands reanneal t7
would not cut them
also if two strands would identical
mutations reanneal t7 won't digest them
heteroduplexes are cleaved and when run
under gel you see the cleave fragments
the ratio of cleave to uncut fragments
can give you an
estimation of a guide rna efficiency
so this next slide shows the t7 assay
done with the first set of crispr
guide rnas we received from miliport
sigma as crnas
we typically design and test three guide
rnas for each target
unless we only find two good potential
guide rna sites
as in the case on the far right side for
the gene pit one
rosa 26 to the left of that is our go-to
positive control
is a very con is very consistent these
two lanes
labeled crc-42 and trrna
do not give t7 cleavage products
wild-type sample can give different
levels of background but hopefully the
t7 bands are stronger than the
non-specific cleavage
the one lanes labeled on the rosa 26 one
day
two day and three day which is not
is not labeled all seem to be equally
efficient
so depending on doesn't matter when we
harvest after the transfection
so the god rnas for the four targets
represented
on this gel all worked well and we were
able to pick the one for each
project that we hoped would give the
best positioning of the donor
ago to put in a mutation allows to
modify the pam and hopefully even
introduce a restriction site for easier
screening
and have a high likelihood of success
so riding along on that high i ordered
the next set of crrnas and look forward
to the results
so this slide shows um you know these
results and not really give me a warm
fuzzy feeling
the rosa 26 control worked as you can
see in the middle of the gel
and it always does but the results for
the others ran the gamut from bad to
terrible
i had them resynthesized and the repeat
results pretty much mirrored these so it
wasn't
an issue of quality just perhaps
limitations of the assay or the target
locus
was perhaps less accessible for the
crispr cas9 complex
so in this case we didn't have complete
choice over which one we could use
these all were for inserting lock's
piece sites so we did have flexibility
because it was not like we wanted to
target a specific amino acid or
constrained by distance from the cut
site
um you know so we were
accustomed to getting results like this
we kind of did not have great confidence
in success of the final project
ultimately the projects worked and in
vivo cutting efficiency in the zygotes
as we surmised by
founder genotyping seem to reflect this
validation we do we got the end result
we wanted but not at high percentage
but we found as long as we see odusi
indels in the cell line validation the
project had a successful conclusion
we had ordered a few hundred more crnas
over the few
last few years and used them
successfully in projects all the
projects worked even with varying
degrees of apparent
crrna efficiency cnr t7 validation
whether they are micro-injected
electro-paraded so
one day caprita asked if i would be
interested in trying full-length
synthetic
sgrna and the results on this slide
always stuck in my head so i said sure i
have a project to insert
loxp sites i'll try crna and
sgrna synthetic sgrna side by side
first invalidation in cells and then
eventually
when we electroporate the zygotes
so this slide shows the comparison of
crna
and synthetic sgrna in cells if you look
to the right side
we see rosa 26 control working as lovely
as ever
and the cr and synthetic sgrna
work with equal efficiency when i looked
at the two target sites the five prime
block speed target
and the three prime target site i was
pretty much blown away i repeated the
transfection the results were similar
the second time around you know i never
get
really sold very quickly on using a new
technology or a new reagent
with regards to crispr gene editing but
the synthetic
sgrna really sold me
not because it would always be better
but the roses because the rosa crna
worked as well as the synthetic sgrna
but i felt at least there may be more
consistency
project to project seeing that in this
case
all six sgrnas clearly outperformed
the crnas we did not actually
compare making the mouse model with crna
versus synthetic
sgrna based on these results
um because i found it hard to justify
comparing the two reagents in a fairly
critical project for this investigator
in one instance though we could have a
reasonable comparison between
c or and synthetic sgrna and that is in
the targeting we did
to the rosa 26 locus
using cr roses 26 labeled crc42
we would get 10 to 15 maybe 20 percent
knock in at the rows of 26 locus putting
in different cdnas
this is using a very common targeting
vector available for mad gene
that have the traditional five prime and
long three prime homology arms
with synthetic sgrnd we saw targeting
efficiency climb to 50
and higher it's not a perfectly
controlled comparison
using rows of 26 cr alone
no targeting vector we would see 70 to
80 percent frequency of indels
at the locus the synthetic sgrna would
give us a higher percentage in those and
very often by allelic mutations
so we saw higher levels of targeting but
we would also see
more biolic mutations if we just wanted
to look at
indels at the rows of locus so in the
next few slides i'll show some examples
of bialylic editing which we see
you know we seem to feel we see much
more often with synthetic sgrna
with the caveat that these are not
side-by-side comparisons with cr
and sgn synthetic sgrna
so this is a gel t7 analysis of founders
for one project the founders marked with
an asterisk
were chosen for ngs analysis not
necessarily hoping that they were
heterozygous
meaning an indel across from wild type
although based on the t7 assay you know
we knew at least the two alleles were
different
so this is a readout of the ngs
we get from the ngs service we use the
number of
reads are usually in the tens of
thousands so we get the depth to clearly
say we have all the alleles identified
in this one founder unless the deletions
are large and excluded from the
from the results the top two alignments
are
two alleles and one founder they have
the highest number of reads
the rest are usually the same alleles
but with pcr artifacts and mismatches
put in by attack polymerase
so this slide shows the summary we sent
to investigators we we sort through all
that data
the founder numbers on the left are
listed on the left and the mutations
seen in their frequency are indicated
in this instance the founders that
looked to be possibly heterozygous by t7
assay had no wild type alleles
i mean this is not a surprise this gene
is not essential
but we would have expected some wild
type alleles based on our previous
experience with
crrna although there is no reason to
absolutely expect that
when we see the t7 results
so this next slide is just another
example
of biolic editing where we did not see
any wild type alleles in the founders
as analyzed by ngs we did not bias our
selection
boundaries that had biologic adding and
editing and again this gene is not
essential although knockouts do have a
distinct metabolic phenotype
at this point we assume we get bialic
editing when we use a good sgrna
based on our t7 validation and cells we
would actually prefer to have indels
across from a wild type allele
maybe synthetic sgrnas are too good
if anything and i'll discuss some ways
later to address this of which i'm sure
many of you are aware
or use yourselves
so this next slide shows a similar
result again about bialyc editing but
this project is for an amino acid change
and then found as we chose again with no
bias
looking or wanting to get by allelic
events there were no wild type alleles
here we don't know if the amino acid
change could do it who could do in the
founder perhaps
it could present as a dominant allele or
affect the founders ability to reach
sexual maturity and and not be able to
transmit the allele
we do like the efficiency in editing but
it can't you know we can have too much
of a good thing sometimes
so on my last slide which summarizes um
some of our ideas i'll go through our
observations
using synthetic sgrna versus crna
so number one i think there's an
increase in cutting efficiency with
sgrna over the two-part system
from the t7 aspect directly comparing
sea artists
synthetic sgrna and the one slide i
showed it was clear that synthetic sg
rna worked better in the assay but the
rows of control look similar regardless
of the source
since that one time and having converted
to using only synthetic sgr
and the rna almost every target gave
us three functioning guide rnas
sometimes only two work this could be
attributed to degradation after
suspension
or the sequence targeted nih-3t3 cells
is not the same as the b6 reference
sequence that are used to design the
guide rnas
and there have been a few instances over
the years where the sequence we want to
target
does not even amplify from the nih 3t3
line so we resort to in vitro digestion
to at least know that this synthetic
sgrna is biologically active
so number two the increase in cutting
efficiency may lead to more biolic
events
this is not an absolute belief but we
almost always find
founders have biolic events in addition
to this we have seen
very good targeting efficiency of
plasmid donors
to every target we have visited
we use reasonably short although not
extremely short homology arms on our
plasmids
we generally go with around seven eight
hundred base pairs on each arm
and these are knock-ins of cree rtta
or fluorescent proteins so we you know
we get very good targeting um and it
seems
much more using synthetic sgrna
so biolic events can be good knock-ins
to rosa-26 for instance
unless a loss of gene function is lethal
we do see bialylic knock-ins like in the
rows of 26 examples are referenced on a
previous slide
and in plasmid knock into other loci
we've made a number of
covert 19 related models recently in the
past few months
all with plasmid-based targeting vectors
in each case the targeting
went very well and we often saw biolegal
targeting events
number four delivery can be adjusted to
effectively reduce cutting efficiency
for example prepare lower concentrations
of rnp
and micro ejection or electroporation
mixes
so we have had to do this in a few
instances it is sometimes a priori not
possible to know if a certain
concentration will give you biolic no
alleles
and or no founders born due to knockout
lethality
but a pubmed search and checking the
jacks mgi website
can perhaps inform us about expected
phenotype looking at previous models
generated or or expression patterns
if we don't expect lethality we like to
go with about 50 nanograms per
microliter protein
and a six-fold molar excess of synthetic
sgrna in our rnp
preparation we will go as high as 100
nanograms per microliter protein when
putting in lox p
sites this may be too high we've seen
biologic editing at lower concentrations
the lowest we have gone is two nanograms
per microliter of cas9 protein
and have had enough editing to
accomplish the project goal
this is just a brief overview of our
experiences using
synthetic sgrna rna i think it has been
beneficial to our work although we have
not done a definitive parallel
comparison
i cannot say this is the only way or
indeed the best way to do things
that works for us and we are always
looking for ways to improve our
efficiency and productivity
i would be happy to answer any questions
later in the webinar or
offline afterwards at any time so thanks
for listening and complete
back to you
thank you for that uh excellent
presentation peter and i'm sure you'll
have prompted some consideration
um and ideas with those results and some
follow-up questions for later
just as a follow-up to that lucky good
timing from my point of view we
actually got a text from one of our
customers in australia
literally last night um basically
echoing exactly what pizza said there so
i won't mention the uh the gene but he
basically said your
gene guides were highly active in vivo
got 68
knockout mice including 55 percent
homozygous so
um single guy do work extremely well um
in terms of
uh animal models and just as um just as
peter said and then
following on from that uh the next set
of experiments that i'm going to show
you were designed to test
how our synthetic guide rnas compared
with those of our competitors in the
mouse model setting
to do this uh eight different gene
targets were
selected um and were assessed for gene
editing efficiency using our guides
as well as guides from two of our
competitors
in this set of experiments the guides
were delivered by
either an embryo micro injection or
embryo electroporation
and the editing was assessed again
in the first set of data shown here what
you can see is that the percentage of
crispr modified alleles
where 15 embryos were micro injected
with guides targeting the psalm 1 gene
in this example the guides from merc
showed um an
average editing efficiency of about 50
whereas when the competitor's guides
were used that average was only 15
even if the results were more consistent
at this target site
but guys clearly outperformed
on the graph on the right we're showing
the average data across
all eight different target sites and
this includes someone
and collectively over 250 embryos to
compare the editing efficiency of our
guides versus
what the aggregated data shows is that
on average our guides perform equally as
well
as that of our competitors or even
slightly better in some cases
we also performed the same set of
experiments in the context of
embryo electroporation as we know many
of our customers are using this method
of delivery for crispr reagents
again using psalm 1 as an example our
guide showed an average
yet highly consistent editing efficiency
of 93
as compared with our competitors who
only showed 42
[Music]
shown to the right is again the average
across all eight different target sites
in a collective total
of almost 250 embryos where either our
guides or competitors guides were used
what we can see here is that again and
even more so in this case
our guides performed equally as well if
not
slightly better
overall our single guide editing
efficiency and embryo electroporation
and micro injection studies performed
equally as well and even better in some
cases than now
so moving on then to a single guide rna
and cell based assays
before i introduce this data let me give
some background to this particular
experiment so we work with chandra
miller at st
jude's hospital on a large collaboration
that involved
six different targets in k562 and u2 os
cells
she did several comparisons number one
comparison between two part unmodified
and modified
one part unmodified modified rna
two a comparison of a couple of
different modification patterns which
ultimately helped us settle on what we
offer today
and three comparison of our rna versus a
competitor
the conclusion over the whole set of
experiments was that in her hands
modified single guide rna works the best
and that hours worked extremely well
when compared to others
the data you see on this slide is the
last data set that we worked on with her
and the purpose of this experiment was
to see whether titrating up the amount
of crna trace rna
would improve the cutting efficiency up
to the levels of modified single guide
iron
one note on the experimental setup their
previous experiments had been conducted
at about one to eight ratio cas9 to
guide rna
so they included one data point at that
concentration as a control
but the titration experiment is done at
a one to two ratio
as they had done multiple experiments by
then to show that
one two two and one to three ratio is
more efficient
for most guide rnas in cell lines that
they tested
the take home message really as you can
see from the data itself is
even at the highest concentrations of
crna and tracer rna
they were not able to get the same
activity as they see with the single
guide rna modified
at the lowest concentration test and
they probably could go lower
to get that same activity one additional
point for me
you can see that the crna works very
well right so you're talking about 40
up to about 70
80 cutting efficiency it's been around a
good while
and is at a slightly lower price point
and is an established and published
product that has been demonstrated to
work across the board
in both cell lines and animal models
hence our decision to continue selling
selling it however if you need the extra
consistency and higher cutting
efficiency then single value rna is
definitely the way to go
this experiment was done by andrew
baffett at the welcome trust sanger
institute
we really wanted to have an evaluation
done in ips cells and andrew has a great
ips model which has one copy of bfp
integrated at the rosa 26 locus which
when altered by basically just two bases
switches the bfp to gfb whereas the
previous set of experiments were all
done for knock out
this experiment is a simple knock in
with a single stranded oligo donut to
alter those two
andrew used a hifi cas9 that they make
themselves in-house
the cr9 trace rnas from a competitor and
is the modifier as is the modified
single guide rna on the far right
and of course the one in the middle is
the modified single value rna here from
that
on the far left you can see the negative
controls with
zero gfp positive cells and 94.7 percent
bfp
from the results you can see that they
were able to get 38.5
gfp positive cells with the two-part
system
but an increase to 45.6 or 46.1
when they used modified single guide rna
showing nicely the utility in ips cells
of
single guide rna and the improvement of
knocking of using single guide
versus two-part rna